مساء الفل
في تحرك زكي ومفاجئ اعلن اكبر بنك في
اوروبا هو اتش اس بي سي البريطاني
استحواذه على ذراع بنك اس في بيل منهار في
بريطانيا مقابل سعر رمزي مقداره واحد
دولار 21 سم خطوه ذكيه جدا من الحكومه
البريطانيه للسيطره على المخاوف وطمانه
الشركات الناشئه البريطانيه اللي لها
ودايع في اسفي بريطانيا وبالتالي هيقدروا
يستكملوا تعاملاتهم المصرفيه بشكل عادي
ويسحبوا ودائعهم بصوره طبيعيه لانها بقت
مدعومه من بنك اتش اس بي سي وبعيدا حتى عن
استقرار النظام المصرفي البريطاني فالصفقه
نفسها تعتبر ممتازه لبنك اتش اس بي سي
لانه رغم افلاس اس بي بي البنك الام اس بي
بريطانيا الا ان اعماله في بريطانيا كانت
مستهره جدا يكفي انك تعرف انه حقق ارباح
في نهايه 2022 بحوالي 88 مليون جنيه
استرليني قبل دفع الضرائب ما تنسوش
تشتركوا في قناه النقط الاقتصاد على
اليوتيوب عشان تتابعوا حلقاتنا المطوله